karl lauterbach ist immer noch krank er
hat corona ist in isolation zu hause und
liefert trotzdem kräftig stoffe
diskussion bei der verwirrung stiftete
es gibt um die 3 monats regel die ja ab
herbst gelten soll diese umstrittene
diese neue lauterbach regel nach drei
monaten nach der impfung gilt man schon
nicht mehr als geimpft laut aber hat zu
dieser regel jetzt vom krankenhausbett
akkus getwittert und zwar dass hier das
schreibt er also glauben sie im ernst
dass menschen sich alle drei monate
impfen lassen um ohne maske in ein
restaurant zu gehen und dann schickt er
dahinter
ich glaub 7 fragezeichen das stiftet
neue verwirrung sagt unser bild meinung
schiff für den fiat auf ihr im studio
warum ja absolut also es geht ja um die
frage wie oft sollen menschen sich
künftig impfen lassen das corona gesetz
dessen entwurf karl lauterbach ja
letztens vorgelegt hat legt genau das
nahe da ist es nämlich wer ins
restaurant geht und keine maske tragen
will der braucht eine frische impfung
also eine impfung die höchstens drei
monate alt das haben die menschen zu
recht als hinweis darauf verstanden dass
sie sich alle drei monate impfen lassen
um diesen krone regeln zu entgehen karl
lauterbach bestreitet das jetzt sagt
quatsch niemand empfiehlt eine 3 also
eine impfung im drei monats takt und hat
sich hier mit einem journalisten auf
twitter angelegt und sagt wer lässt sich
denn alle drei monate impfen um ins
restaurant zu gehen das passiert nicht
und dann schiebt er noch hinterher
und wenn wir sehen würden dass das
passiert dann machen wir diese ausnahme
wieder dicht dabei hat er doch gesagt er
wählt das als anreiz für die impfung
haben ganz genau als er diesen
gesetzentwurf vorgestellt hat hat er in
der ard erklärt diese regelung sei ein
guter impf anreiz der können wir einmal
kurz reinhören
das ist in den bars und in den
restaurants die ausnahme gibt dass man
frisch geimpft oder genesen sein kann
das ist ein anreiz für die impfung also
das ist
absolut offenbar merkt er dass dort
mindestens kommunikativ etwas komplett
aus dem ruder gelaufen ist denn man kann
den menschen ja nicht sagen hey wenn ihr
geimpft sein die impfung ist höchstens
drei monate alt dann müsst ihr im
restaurant keine maske tragen und wenn
die menschen sich dann wundern na ja
soll ich mich jetzt alle drei monate
impfen lassen dann sagt der
gesundheitsminister plötzlich nein das
war noch nie so gemeint und dann bleibt
wirklich die frage was meint ihr denn
mit dem zweiten teils industrie zwar
sagte wenn wir sehen dass sich menschen
drei alle drei monate entlassen dann
heben wir die ausnahmeregelungen für sie
wieder auf ich habe heute versucht das
bundesgesundheitsministerium zu fragen
was was meint ihr denn damit wird die
ausnahmeregelung für frisch kämpfte
wieder aufgehoben dass sie also auch
maske tragen müssen dass das denn zu
verstehen was der minister vom
krankenbett twittert aber da hieß es nur
zurück der tweet so selbsterklärend geht
so ich muss sagen je länger wir darüber
reden ich finde da jetzt dafür wird er
blickt man in richtung herbst philipp
deswegen bitte einmal serviceleistungen
erbringen fast für mich einmal zusammen
muss ich mich jetzt noch mal impfen
gehen was gilt für mich in einem im
herbst ist es ganz leicht und simpel zu
beantworten selbstverständlich nicht nur
vertrieben wird na ja so schön es wäre
schön das wünschen sich glaube ich sehr
viele bürger also es gibt derzeit von
der ständigen impfkommission von der
stiko keine empfehlung für dich für eine
vierte impfung die im empfiehlt das
bislang nur über 70-jährigen bürgern die
frage ist also was ist mit dem gesamten
rest karl lauterbach wünscht sich
natürlich auch wenn es vielleicht nicht
ganz offen sagt dass die stiko die
vierte impfung für alle bürger empfiehlt
oder zumindest auch für viele menschen
unter 70 unter 60 er selbst ist hier
beispielsweise vierfach kämpft dennoch
hat ihn corona erwischt die impfungen
die vierte informiert jetzt mehr als
drei monate zurück hier ist es aus dem
bmg dennoch hat es karl lauterbach
erwischt auch nicht symptomfrei er hat
jetzt getwittert dass es dass er sich
auf dem wege der besserung befindet
schauen wir noch mal ganz kurz hatte
nämlich gerade erst fünf minuten etwa
ist das alt karl lauterbach also vom
krankenbett aus fleißig bei twitter da
hat er eine ganze reihe von frischen
corona tests getwittert das ist noch der
alte das ist das neue ding um die korona
tests können wir gleich noch mal drauf
gucken und hier sagt er dann eben die
letzten vier tage langsam geht's
aufwärts aber corona ist keine
kleinigkeit wissen wir trotz vier
impfungen und pavlov sieht hätte ich
stärker hat die stärkere symptome als
erwartet da können wir uns drauf gucken
auf die striche dort die werden so
langsam etwas blasser bei karl
lauterbach ja und jetzt eben zur frage
was was gilt zurzeit ist eben geplant
dass man in restaurants im kino und
museen maske tragen muss oder einen
frischen test vorliegen muss wenn man
eben nicht frisch gemacht ist wenn die
impfung also älter als drei monate alt
ist und zwar eben die vierte impfung ob
das sich durchsetzt ist eine andere
frage denn damit das überhaupt erstmal
gesetzt wird braucht es eine mehrheit im
parlament und wir hören dass es aus der
fdp-fraktion deren justizminister
buschmann diese regelung mit erarbeitet
hat durchaus widerstand gibt weil die
sagen verzeihung alle drei monate sich
impfen lassen um dann im restaurant
nicht maske zu tragen während unsere
nachbarn sich wirklich einfach komplett
verabschieden von ihrem chor ohne regeln
wollen wir jetzt noch mal eins drauf
satteln und die bürger weiter mit diesen
regelungen malträtieren das geht einfach
nicht deswegen es bleibt spannend aber
ich machte mich jetzt überhaupt noch
keine prognose dass im herbst gelten
wird ja ich glaube es ist mehr als
seriös genau das zu tun nämlich noch
keine prognose abzugeben du wirst uns
trotzdem auf dem laufenden natürlich
halten damit wir alle wissen an welche
regeln wir uns denn dann wieder runter
[Musik]